hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen
lebenssinn und gerade bei der gamescom
und ihr seht jetzt schon wieder
eingeblendet die spiele pokémon gaulle
auf wie ein bisschen rum und versucht
ihren puppen anzufangen deswegen gehen
wir jetzt
ich weiß ja wir hätten durch kann man
wir versuchen zwar müsst wissen wie
lange fünf tage fünf tage fünf tage die
sind am letzten tag um 17 uhr also eine
stunde verschließen weil es ist das 19
deswegen ist er gar nichts für mich
verfolgt
wir gehen wir anders wissen ich würde
echt und reagieren in den hallen spielen
nur da sind irgendwie solches apps
störer drin und ich kann man nicht was
passiert wenn man mit dem pokémon geht's
hier in die halle läuft
es geht wir sind jetzt in der halle in
der nächsten tauziehen das kann man sich
auf jeden fall mal gönnen ich wollte
euch eigentlich mal meine pokemon zeigen
weil ich bin jetzt 23
die komplette gamescom ist tot
alle tot
hier sind überhaupt keine menschen wo
wir am tomate und dem ok das schiff
läuft hier übrigens sorry falls ist
alles reibungslos läuft mit video und
helligkeit und zu aber wir nehmen gerade
die kamera von zeppelin genfer
einstellungs halt gemacht oder dem tempo
das neu zu starten weil wir im moment
hätten rausgeschmissen
da putzen die sogar rat schon was ich
eigentlich machen wollte war ich meine
besten topmann zeichnet sich derzeit
kokowääh mit 1116 dann einladung 2710
dann noch in kairo auf 1600 ein
elektriker 1400 galopp auf 1400
einwohner von 3000 euro und ich habe
glaube ich noch ich habe doch irgendwas
geil entwickeln ich weiß gar nicht was
aber damals nie 2000 oder so ich habe
mich in lockhausen ich habe ein total
von patches local content comcom die
leute dann in koffern an ein paar
sekunden später
mein bein gebrochen hatte und hauptstadt
finden das cool und ich dachte auch weil
der gamescom sind überall pokerstop gut
und schön aber es ist nichts und ich
glaube wieder nicht wir stehen wieder
auf der stelle
ich bin 23 punkten also keiner kann man
was die glücklichste häcksler okay gut
markenfilm oh mein gott
sicher versuchen sich gleich weiter
das ist ja echt beschissen das wetter
werden draußen alle noch ein bisschen
ein fan situation zimmer kurz den regen
der falter wir machen jetzt schnell und
lauf zurück dass dies folgen
immer ihr silber nette menschen
ich bin mal kurz den profis dabei ist
auch witzig wenn meine puppen und videos
sondern sich eigentlich gar nicht im
pokémon eigentlich vielmehr wegen der
andere scheiße also ich wollte euch
eigentlich mal zeigen wieso gerade der
stand bei mindestens 123 brauchen jetzt
125000 schon ein paar arien besiegt man
beutel ist gerade voll und ich habe geld
investierte den kuratoren und kann jetzt
nämlich 5 x 5 kilometer- heraus bringen
übrigens letztes ich hatte zehn
kilometer und was war drin in 13
kilometer 13 mal mit glück vielleicht
bei games kommt klärt vor als rico an
der street parade kam nie wieder eine
gamescom fuchs geht wieder richtig geil
weil einfach nichts in der nähe ist wir
haben traummaße auf sie zukommt ich
bewege mich wieder nicht richtig laufen
ob das spiel nicht laufen jetzt einfach
wieder nicht inzwischen bereit wo er
vorhin schon waren und gucken aufwiegt
jeden wo was fangen können will
sonst habe ich jetzt ein video macht
mich einfach nur dumm aber dass meine
besten pokémon sind und konnte quasi
nicht fangen in die richtung dass auch
wir waren freunde in der halle da hinten
so dagegen überhaupt nichts entschieden
sagt wirz film du dummkopf kombis tronic
es regnet weil wir natürlich und das
alles doch schlüpfen würde aber das
braucht noch 800 meter 19 kilometer
schluckt wo die legendäre pokémon fangen
ich glaube
wir helfen
lukas besteht das video nun auf den
ausgang suchen ich nehme mal offen habe
rollrasen rollrasen mit nehme ein paar
sekunden später
ich habe nur ein rasend schnell wissen
bislang lag zwei probleme das erste
probleme ich laufe schon wieder nicht
bei pokemon das zweite problem ist
überall fahnen leute mit welchen
gabelstaplern rum und
der schöne pass man ein turnier brauchen
bei dem ein loch 290 metern ich denke
das müsste passen bis zum auto
der notausgang ist der hat die ganze
zeit wahrscheinlich irgendwie sondern
flackern im licht oder so wir dachten
dass ich mir den kameraeinstellungen
aber das liegt wohl daran bis in den
messehallen wieder komplett beschissenes
lichtl verkennt doing gefordert gamescom
ist für seine hohen stocks nicht
ich bin werfer für mich ist ja okay wir
haben jetzt endlich etwas erreicht und
zwar ein hohes top den wir drehen können
ein beutel ist voll
[ __ ] my life und freunde ich habe ein
ticket ist ob sie an und sehe das traut
sie befindet sich wenn ich eher an mache
genau wir das parkett ob sie bei der
gamescom gefahren
da muss man erst mal machen v pcy wp 4
sie kann schon wieder sechs mal
entwickeln und pp abzuzocken erwerb
angeboten
ich will unbedingt wissen wie dieser
werwolf ist weil das es gibt doch in
köln so ein punkt habe ich gewinne ein
wein kork weinkopf ich stelle ihn kurz
danach begann trainer tim cook
postpaid müsse man wollte ist nur noch
die schweiz etwas raus alter bissig mark
bomback das game und so aber ich bin
doch mittlerweile ein bisschen besser
geworden sich für level 23 aber so das
ding ist ich weiß ich nicht
youtube-videos damit füllen soll also
schreibe ich die kommentare was ich
machen soll
damit ich lerne endlich
wir sind jetzt auf dem parkplatz
angekommen wir haben nicht viel glück
ich kann das 599 aber eigentlich direkt
wieder verschicken weil ich das alles in
meinem kopf
es ist jetzt gleich von 1809 coco war
ist jetzt wp 1915 hat übrigens die
attacken konfusion bitter 15 und solaris
120 euro ford capri arena in kolomna
also freunde kleiner hinweis wenn ihr
reden einnehmen wollten ja direkt an ja
keine ahnung also gelaufen jetzt auf
jeden fall zum auto oder steht dort
vorne 100 metern
deswegen würde ich sagen ich kenne das
video jetzt an dieser stelle werden euch
das video gefallen dass ich mich auf
eine bewertung freuen wir haben wirklich
nicht viel gemacht ich hatte nur letzter
tag gamescom gefahren haben wir neben
der kamera mit filmt irgendwie was mal
schauen ob man den pokémon fans auf die
gefahren ich habe oben offen
geworben
ja gut mich den mitten auf dem parkplatz
gerade was will man erwarten ich will
meine bewertungen freuen was euch im
nächsten pongau wir machen schreibt die
kommentare hallo und herzlich willkommen
hier im anschluss des videos die ich
wollte euch nur mal kurz was fragen
deswegen bleibt bitte noch kurzen minute
daran mir ist im schnitt dieses videos
irgendwie aufgefallen das ist mir ultra
viel spaß gemacht hat
das zuschneiden weil ich einfach so viel
scheiße gebaut habe ich frage mich nur
was bei euch gut ankommt deswegen mache
ich jetzt ein kleines experiment und
zwar das kommt davon wenn man die kamera
an so ein geländer spannend ich wollte
euch eigentlich nur sagen bitte wenn ihr
weiterhin bock auf pokémon go videos hat
auch wenn ich nicht so viel reise wir
ein oder andere pokémon youtuber dann
schreibt bitte mal in die kommentare
einfach nur pokemon go und dann weiß ich
okay jeder kommentar der einfach
wirklich nur ganz stumpf pokémon
kommentiert hat will dass ich weiter in
pongau videos machen mit ja diesen
sachen die ich bisher gemacht habe
das war doch eigentlich schon also wenn
sie euch gefallen lassen like da und
wenn ihr noch mehr pongau sehen wollten
schreibt pokorny kontert ich erklärt ab
in die sonne weil es in 230 gerade sein